[Música]
boa noite é então é esse rita x me isso
não é uma coisa que a autoria de
pensamento é é a gente tem perdido nas
últimas décadas a autoria a capacidade
de ver as coisas e de fazer as coisas de
um modo único é e comigo é como
transformar a casa em obra de arte foi
na minha infância e novos alagados na
plataforma uma área de palafitas e uma
casa que a gente ficava e essa casa
tinha livros discos e obras de arte
e nessa casa o coração da gente foi
mudado porque pobreza não é falta de
cultura
as casas mais importantes da vida da
gente
elas são definidas pela simplicidade que
vem da cultura e por esse motivo a casa
então se tornou pra mim um lugar o único
lugar de aura a casa não é banal
ela é um espaço de intimidade do
encontro da vida ela é de suma
importância do universo cultural da
cidade com suas funções simbólicas uma
casa não pode ser vilipendiada uma casa
um lugar de produção de conhecimento uma
casa o espaço de onde emana a vida da
cidade ea casa como obra de arte nada
mais é do que a revelação do mistério
que nós cada um de nós temos porque nós
viemos de uma casa e de uma casa mítica
que tem uma poética própria que foi
criada com o esforço com sacrifício ea
criação no tempo revela o esforço de
múltiplas mãos sonhos investimentos com
a força que vem da vida
a casa protege a briga em todas as
dimensões ea arte amplia as nossas
possibilidades de ser que toda a casa
elaborada de voto que essa beleza
refugão na cidade mas há pessoas que não
se dão conta da grandeza do câmbio viveu
uma casa com essa intensidade e vivem de
modo banal nem se dão conta da força que
essa casa tem criar um aterro na casa da
gente a laje foi a oportunidade de tirar
a nossa casa da banalidade ponto e possa
possibilitar a emergência de poéticas
que até então a gente nem se dava conta
que existia e fazer do acervo da loja a
gente começou educar uma comunidade e
começou a educar uma população e começou
a educar artistas e começou a educar uma
cidade elitista que achava que os museus
só deveriam ficar no centro dela e
educar uma cidade é receber essa cidade
em sua casa e trazer a arte pra casa nos
proteger da violência nos tirou da adobe
e antp os estigmas e criou que novos
campos simbólicos que estão protegendo
crianças e adolescentes escolas e
estudantes que estão indo visitá esse
acervo só pra dizer pra vocês que o
improvável e triste que o improvável
existe e que a gente tem que acreditar
nos sonhos da gente a gente tem que
acreditar que quando você compra uma
obra de arte de um artista de sua cidade
e essa obra fica na sua casa e as
pessoas vêem e com que tenho contato com
aquela obra autoral única e isso
possibilita possibilita que os moradores
criadores e artistas que são expoentes
da ferida aberta pelo encontro com a
beleza digam que esse é o seu pode
operativo de cuidar das vidas das outras
pessoas porque a arte faz com que a
gente cuide da vida de outras pessoas
não é só a decoração de uma casa mas não
é esse coração generoso que a gente tem
porque a gente receber
ou de outras pessoas que nos precederam
é pra que a nossa casa fosse essa obra
de arte como é que constitui uma casa
com uma obra de arte
primeiro é uma residência é um lugar
humano para receber pessoas humanas e
como humano merece tudo de bom
a beleza tem que estar presente dele é
um espaço expositivo cultural é uma obra
autoral é única é elaborada a gente
pensou a casa ea boa casa e arquitetura
dela é nova ea narrativa sobre como
transformar a casa uma obra de arte é
justamente pinta indicar o seguinte deus
de violência no mestrado doutorado e eu
não recebia de ninguém
quando a gente começou a descobrir que o
que protege da violência beleza
isso começou aí da cidade de salvador
e aí nós fizemos ocupa lages e olhando
surfa e filma e ocupa lá a gente pode
levar essa proposta para várias lojas da
cidade salvador da periferia com
oficinas exposições e intervenções
artísticas e isso mostrou que sim é
possível e essa idéia mudou a face de
salvador em fevereiro a junho deste ano
é por favor o vídeo
[Música]
ae
[Aplausos]
não é isso esse teste x como é que tá
pra conectar pessoas é isso gente eu
acho que a gente tem que acreditar nas
idéias que a gente tem é e tem aprendido
que aprender a amar a cidade que a gente
tem e os artistas que nós temos porque
quando a gente faz essas ações a gente
está protegendo vidas que sempre foram
excluídas dos circuitos históricos e
artísticos da cidade
então ou com palavras acho que foi esse
presente para a cidade é ea gente espera
que como é que tá tanta gente milhares
de pessoas através da arte tanto na
bienal da bahia contabilidade de são
paulo quanto no cu palavra para dizer o
seguinte acredita nos sonhos de vocês
e acreditem na autoria pensamento do
modo de elaboração que vocês bem porque
é isso que faz a nossa diferença nesse
pedaço de terra chamado mundo
boa noite